you know
the most important thing is that you do
figure it out sometimes people figure it
out
i see people in their like 20s now that
are
that feel that seem like they have their
[ __ ] together more than i ever did
you know um and then i see you know
people in their
50s and that are just now figuring
life out i don't know i i think we all
kind of perceive things at different
levels at different times and
um where we get it when we're ready i
guess
you know have you ever just sat there
and thought you know what if it just
ended now
if it just if i just [ __ ] off to
moosejaw saskatchewan and just said [ __ ]
it no one ever sees my wife and i and
all the kids whatever they probably
won't go with you to moose job but if
you went there
and you're up in moose jaw and you're
thinking what have i done
and you're like well i was on the
biggest show in the world which gave me
huge success
i was a finalist i got a record deal i
had two hits
i well i mean you're the fastest selling
debut rock album
in nielsen soundscan history a million
copies in five weeks right after idol
right this is like
the first album so and then you look at
all this stuff you know you
made albums you've played with all your
[ __ ] heroes a lot of your heroes that
you love i see a picture on [ __ ]
instagram with you and sammy hagar and
you know you're playing with all these
people that are just amazing
so why couldn't you just go that's
enough
well i didn't expect this i could be in
north carolina playing a [ __ ]
right it's it's certainly uh
those conversations get get bounced
around often
me and my wife are always like what if
we just go live in the woods somewhere
oh my god
and and just escape everything like
how bad could it be um we were watching
uh
we're just watching uh this donkey
series
on netflix with zac efron have you seen
that no but i want
down down to earth dude it's so good i
haven't finished it yet but we were
watching going
like that's life you know they're these
people are happy they're
growing their own food i want to be down
to earth
yeah i want to be just grounded and
not worry about [ __ ] um but yeah man
it's you know and then there's that part
of me that feels like
you know i i and and sometimes i feel
guilty for it but
like i feel like i need that i need to
be on stage and i need to
be in the studio and creating and um
at some capacity so it's it's it's one
of those things that
um i feel like i still have a lot left
in me but certainly there are times
where it's like
what if you know i do it all the time
man in fact tomorrow i'm going up with
my best friend
we're going to drive a couple hours to
big bear and just look at some cabins to
maybe buy
i want to buy like a here you go i just
want to be able to get out of town and
you know just to be able to i think what
happens is sometimes you're like what am
i doing it's like this cyclical
it's you're busy you're being productive
you're
doing things you're enjoying things but
it seems sort of
at the same time stagnant almost like
yeah you're doing the same things and
everything's great but it's also you
don't want 20 years to go by and go
you watch these shows like you said with
the zac efron you know down to earth and
you watch
alone that i watch in the history
channel that i talk about i had jordan
jonas the winner of season six on
he's out there and he's like building a
shelter
and he's like not to say you have to do
that but you know
fishing and building a fire and just
getting away and i don't get away and i
keep saying i need to get away
and that you know it's it's the same
thing it's like as important as this
stuff is
you're probably we are probably going to
be healthier if we do
disconnect for a bit and then come back
stronger because if we just keep pushing
we never get away we always talk about
it and then something comes up that we
can't get away because of this
because of this i'm with the kids or or
i got this virtual tour
i'm doing now and then it is always
something and it's almost like you just
have to like
intentionally just cut it cut the cord
and yeah
and disappear why don't you put it on
the schedule why don't you and your wife
say let's pick a date
and we're we're doing it we're circling
it right now all we're doing is putting
this
we're not changing this date we're doing
this for our own sanity yeah that's what
needs to happen i need to do that too